the zoo was never going to compete with
with police fire and safety
americans love animals everyone from
Betty White to Newt Gingrich more than
150 million Americans visit zoos every
year but many zoos are in trouble budget
cuts are forcing many zoos to make up
for funding shortfalls by laying off
workers cutting important educational
programs reducing operating hours
deferring maintenance and raising ticket
prices we spoke with the reason
foundations director of Government
Reform to understand the problem the
National League of Cities recently put
out a report that showed that for six
years straight cities have been facing
declining revenues meeting every single
year revenues are coming in lower and
lower and so when budgets get tight
there is considerable pressure on
policymakers to keep funding what you
might call the core priorities things
like public safety infrastructure and so
what that means is we're going to have
to have an increasing role for the
private sector to handle all of those
other things and that citizens have
become accustomed to before we got into
the tighter fiscal climate that we're
seeing today I mean we can expect to see
into the future public-private
partnerships using the private sector is
a terrific opportunity Dewey Bartlett
became mayor of Tulsa Oklahoma during a
budget crisis in 2009 we simply could
not afford the capital contribution
necessary to get our zoo up to where it
would receive accreditation but also
would be an enjoyable experience for our
community so we made a decision
privatize it change the operations get
people involved that are committed to
operating our zoo properly but also have
a business perspective let's see what we
can do to enhance the experience but
also get more people to come and get
more money become more attractive the
situation that Tulsa Zoo prior to the
public-private partnership was one where
the zoo was declining both with this
infrastructure and the staffs ability to
take care of the zoo because of city
budget cuts one of the primary reasons
cities are looking to public-private
partnerships to operate their cultural
amenities is because it allows the city
to draw down its subsidy and what you
find is that the private sector and
philanthropists are more willing
to give donations to nonprofits when
they operate these things because they
trust the nonprofit more to do right
with the money you are taking an entity
who has a vested interest in a certain
asset like a friends of the zoo type
organization and you're giving them more
responsibility not just to be a
supplemental partner in fundraising and
other sort of lower scale activities but
actually turning over the operation to
someone who has a vested interest in
seeing it succeed the difference between
the public the public private
partnership and being under city
management is we basically now have all
of our staff works for one organization
which is Tulsa Zoo Management
incorporated a not-for-profit
organization as opposed to a portion of
the staff working for the city and a
portion of the staff working for the
nonprofit and so I think that there's
just a better cohesiveness to the group
that things like policies and procedures
are the same now for everybody and
although that sounds small it isn't so
small they are able to receive the funds
that are generated by admissions etc so
they have a revenue stream we committed
to a specific amount of money every year
but no more now they've taken over that
operation they've had it out for a
couple years and they're doing a very
very good job the public is reacting
really well to the public-private
partnership through our members and
visitors donors that come out to the zoo
they can't believe the turnaround and
it's small things it's having cleaner
grounds more well kept grounds making
small improvements in some of the
familiar animal exhibits like our
flamingo yard seeing the brand-new sea
lion exhibit our attendance has
increased over fourteen percent from
last year to this year those type of
expansions would not have been possible
under just city management because the
zoo is never going to be able to compete
with streets and safety about 75% of the
accredited urban zoos and aquariums in
this country are run through
public-private partnerships and that's
something many citizens probably don't
even notice is they think that their
city is the one that's running the zoo
when in fact the city may technically
own that asset but it's the private
sector through nonprofit arrangements
that are actually operating those
amenities and actually investing more
then the cities would be able to do
themselves under constrained budgets
you